okay so this is the crash course on
sampling
and uh
so there are some some additional
references so first of all you find the
slides of this talk on my homepage which
is here and
you also find some lecture notes of a
course on mcmc methods that we gave last
year on my home page
and this has much more material than i
can talk about now
and another nice reference are these
lecture notes by montenegro and tetley
on mathematical aspects of mixing times
of markov chains that you also find in
the internet
and then there is some complementary
reference
so this is not really on the material
i'll be talking about here but
complementary so this is about markov
chains with a finite state space and
their mixing times
yes the very nice book by levine paris
and wilma
okay
so now let's start
so here we're looking at
probability measures on rd
so we assume that we are given a
probability measure mu on rd
and we assume it has a density with
respect to the back measure
and we write the density in the form 1
over a normalization constant
times e to the minus u of x
this density is also denoted by mu of x
[Music]
now to make the connection to the
optimization course yesterday so in
optimization we had this function f
appearing and this function f is now
replaced by this function u here
so yesterday we wanted to minimize
such a function and now instead of
wanting to minimize we want to sample
from a probability measure with density
proportional to e to the minus u
now so our goal is to generate
approximate samples from
[Music]
we can also make another
connection to optimization
so suppose instead of considering this
measure here we consider measure with
density e to the minus beta u of x times
a normalizing constant
then if we let beta go to infinity
then this measure concentrates on the
global minima of u or near the global
minima of u
so that means if we could simulate mu
beta for every beta and then let beta go
to infinity
then we could also find the global
minimum
okay so now to the sampling problem
there are many approaches to sampling
and
let me first briefly describe some
simple classical approaches
so first of all there are direct methods
you can somehow directly sometimes
directly create numerically samples
so for example if you have a probability
measure on r1
then you can just create a uniform
random number
and then you apply the generalized
inverse of the distribution function to
that uniform random number
and that gives you a sample from your
measurement
so if you have access to this
generalized inverse of the distribution
function
then this gives you an algorithm to to
generate samples from you but this is
limited to the one-dimensional case
something more general is acceptance
rejection
so in acceptance rejection we have
another probability measure mu
and we assume that we're already able to
create samples from mu
so nu is called the proposal
distributions because we propose samples
from u
then we assume that the measure we're
interested in has a density with respect
to nu a density proportional to row of x
and we assume that this function rho is
upper bounded by a constant c
okay so then we can create samples
from mu in the following way so we first
create a sample from mu
then we create independently a uniform
random number
which we call u
and then if u is smaller than rho of x
over c
then we accept this sample from mu as a
sample from mu
and otherwise we we create a new sample
from mu
again uh draw a new uniform random
number and again if this holds we accept
and otherwise we start again and so on
so this will terminate in finite time
and it will create us an exact sample
from you
what's the disadvantage well the
disadvantage is often the running time
so what can we say about the running
time sorry for that
i have to go up again
so what can we say about the running
time of this algorithm
well
since
sorry
okay since we are creating here iib
samples
the number of steps we need until we get
acceptance is geometrically distributed
with parameter p
and here p is one over c times the
integral of rho with respect to the
measure nu
okay so that means the average running
time that's the expectation of t and
this is one over p
and one over p is this constant c
divided by this integral
now the point is that c is often very
large
so for example if you're in high
dimensions if you have a product model
then c will grow exponentially in the
dimension
so that means your running time
typically will grow exponentially in the
dimension
at least in many situations so it will
often be too large
so although in special situations this
is useful and it's definitely useful as
a building block
in other
algorithms usually on its own
this will not be sufficient
okay so because of that
we have to give up something
and now we are looking no longer at
creating exact samples but we are only
asking can we create approximate samples
and
the most widely used method for creating
approximate samples is markov chain
monte carlo
and that's what i will talk about today
so the idea in markov chain monte carlo
is that you create a markov chain
which has mu as its invariant measure
and then you simulate this markov chain
for a long time
and then you hope that it has nice
ergodic properties
and that after a long time its law it
has mixed well
and so its law is approximately equal
to the equilibrium distribution
and then you take a sample from the
markov chain after a long time
and this gives you an approximate sample
from your measurement
okay so to make it more precise in order
to
define this markov chain we need a
transition kernel
and the transition kernel is a
probability kernel on rd
so what's the probability kernel this is
just a measurable function in the first
variable and the probability measure in
the second variable
okay and then we assume
that our measure mu is an invariant
measure for this probability kernel
what does that mean well that means
this
equation here so mu of b is equal to mu
pi of v
what's mu pi of b this is just the
integral over rd with respect to the
measure mu
of pi xb
yeah so this is the law
if you start with mu after the next step
of the markov chain and so this identity
says that if you start with mu then in
the next step you also have long u so
that means mu is preserved that means
invariant
okay so that's what you what you usually
want you want the markov chain which has
new as its invariant measure
sometimes
you even make a something
less restrictive you allow that that
your measure that mu is only
approximately equal to mu pi
yeah so that would be some relaxation
here but most of the time we will assume
that the two are equal
okay so then you want to create a markov
chain
with this transition kernel pi so you
start with some initial distribution
that you can choose so the initial
distribution will be a probability
measure on rd again
and this you can choose
if the markov chain has very good mixing
properties then you can basically choose
what you like because the markov chain
will forget its initial law
rapidly
but if the mixing properties are maybe
not so good or you don't know
then maybe you have to think about also
to make a good choice for the initial
distribution
[Music]
okay so then you create a markov chain
that means a stochastic process such
that x0 is distributed according to new
and then the transition mechanism from
one step to the next is given by this
transition kernel pi
okay if you do that
then the law at time t of your markov
chain
is denoted by nu t so that's just the
probability that x t is in b
so so the distribution after t steps of
your markov chain
this is just given by the product new pi
to the t
now so so you just apply the transition
kernel t times to the measurement
okay so that's your law at time t
and now the idea or the hope is that if
t is sufficiently large
then
under certain assumptions
then mu t will be close to mu in some
sense and that means a sample from new t
which is given by x t will be an
approximate sample from u
of course there are now a lot of
question marks that have to be made
precise so for example what does
sufficiently large mean
what does this approximately equal here
mean so here we need some distance
between probability measures or
something like that
and then
can we prove this implication and in
particular under which assumptions does
it code
yeah so there are a lot of questions
that need to be answered
need they boil down to the following
key questions
so
the the main question is you you want to
get upper and lower bounds
for w new t mu
where w is
either some distance function on
probability measures or what is called
divergence divergence is some kind of
non-symmetric distance function
a distance function this can for example
be total variation distance
or some wasserstein distance so you want
to bound these distances
to to the target
and
divergence this can for example be the
chi-square divergence or the quebec lipo
divergence which is the same as the
relative entropy
okay so you want to get upper and lower
bounds for these
four different types of markov chains
and
you can also formulate it in a different
way in terms of mixing and relaxation
times
so what is the mixing time well if
you're given a distance w then you can
define
a mixing time according to this distance
so so you give a parameter epsilon so
that's given that's a positive number
and then you define the mixing time with
parameter epsilon
as the minimum of all times
such that the distance of mu t to mu
is smaller than epsilon times the
distance of the initial order
now so that means
it's the first time where for all
initial laws your distance has decayed
by a factor epsilon
okay so this you can define for general
distances
now for total variation distance you
usually use a slightly different
definition and that's because total
variation distances are always bounded
by one
so therefore you drop
this one here so you define the total
variation
mixing time is the minimum of all t
such that the total variation distance
from mu t to mu is smaller than epsilon
for any initial only
okay so now if you do that
then it turns out that this total
variation mixing time will usually be
infinite on unbounded state spaces
so that's not a good definition so you
have to modify it
and
what you do is you restrict to compact
sets so you choose sum set k
and then you define the total variation
mixing time on the set k
to be the first time such that the total
variation distance after t is smaller
than epsilon but now only for all
probability measures that live on the
set k
so you only allow initial laws in this
compact set k
and in that way you get something finite
[Music]
okay so that's another way to measure
convergence to equilibrium and there are
corresponding time
times related to divergences
and these are called relaxation times
sorry for that
okay
then there's a third question
that's of interest but that i do not
have the time to discuss today
and that's bounds for ergodic averages
because
why do you want to create your samples
well there are different purposes but
one purpose is often to estimate
integrals numerically
and how how can you estimate integrals
so integral of a function f with respect
to the probability measure mu how can
you estimate that numerically well you
can use the ergodic theorem and
approximate it by ergodic averages so
you take such an average from
time b to b plus t minus 1
where b is called the burn in so that's
a given number of steps that you ignore
and then you average over the next t
steps
yeah and then the ergodic theorem tells
you that under certain conditions that
should be close
to integral f d mu and then you want to
quantify the probability that the
distance is greater than epsilon say
okay so that's another problem which is
closely related to the other two
problems but it's not the same
okay so which mathematical approaches
are there to get bounce
on mixing times and things like that
well basically there are two
families of approaches one is more
probabilistic the other more analytic
first family are coupling methods so
they use couplings
and i i will explain this afterwards in
more detail
but there are different types of
couplings so for example you can just
look at couplings of the transition
kernels
of your markov chain for example
and this will be closely related to
contractions in wasserstein distances
or you can look at couplings of markov
processes
so here you do not just couple adjust
the kernel but the whole process
and
this also gives you bounce for example
through the coupling lemma
this is just an overview we'll come to
that
or you can look at special couplings for
diffusion processes so processes in
continuous time
and there's also something which is not
really only coupling which is called
harris serum or we carry
so that combines
some coupling side cutting ideas some
minorization or wasserstein contraction
with elephant function
so these are more probabilistic
approaches and then there are more
analytic approaches based on functional
inequalities and the first approach is
conductance we'll come to that in a
moment
[Music]
here you do not really see the
functional inequality but it's actually
equivalent to one
and
others are spectral gaps which are
linked to poincare inequalities
logarithmic several of inequalities and
then more recent approaches
for non-reversible markov processes
based on hypocoercivity and so on
so that's just a short overview and some
of these things i'll come to now
okay so how do we get a markov chain
with the right invariant measure well
the most well known known procedure is
the metropolis algorithm or more
generally metropolis hastings
okay so here what we are doing is
we first have another probability kernel
which is not the transition kernel of
our markov chain but which is used to
create proposals
so we have another probability kernel p
x d y
which can be rather arbitrary
but we assume that it has a density with
respect to the back measure and we
assume that the density is strictly
positive
okay and now
the idea is to modify these transitions
here so that you get the right invariant
measure
and this modification is again done by
an acceptance rejection procedure
so you now construct the markov chain
and its transition step is given by the
following algorithm so if you add x you
move to x prime
in the following way
so you first create a sample from your
proposal kernel
and again you sample a uniform random
number independently
and now
you accept your move with a certain
probability
namely you accept it if your uniform
random number is smaller than this
quotient here
okay so what's this quotient here
well
the numerator so this is the flow from y
to x
and the denominator is the probability
flow from x to y
so you look at the quotient of the two
if the two are equal then you have a
detailed balance condition and that
implies invariance
so so if
numerator and denominator are already
equal then you have invariance but if
they are not equal then you look at this
quotient
and then you only accept with a
probability which is determined by this
quotient
so if you accept then you move to y and
otherwise you just stay where you are at
position x
okay so in that way you define a markov
chain and what's the transition kernel
well you have this
sorry for that
didn't happen before to me
i don't know why this is happening
okay
so
this defines the markov chain and what's
the transition kernel of the markov
chain so you have the proposal kernel p
and then it gets multiplied by the
acceptance probability a x y
and then you have another probability r
of x that you reject and in that case
you stay at x
okay so what's the acceptance
probability well the acceptance
probability is essentially this number
here
but this number can be greater than one
so if it's greater than one then you
always accept
so therefore the acceptance probability
is the minimum of this ratio and one
okay and then the rejection probability
that's just the remaining probability
for not accepting integrated overall
proposed moves
okay so now it's easy to check that your
measure mu is really an invariant
measure for pi
yeah so that's a little exercise
and actually you can show a bit more you
can show the detailed balance condition
you can show that the flow from x to y
is the same as the flow from y to x
if you don't like this notation here
with the measures just write it with
densities so mu of x
pi x y is the same as mu of y pi y x
also you have the detailed balance
condition
and this condition is actually stronger
than the invariance
actually if you integrate this condition
here over x over the whole state space
then you get the invariance then you get
that new pi is equal to mu
yeah so we have
a better condition than in variance we
have detailed balance which corresponds
to reversibility of the markov chain
with invariant with initial or mu
okay so now here you can choose your
proposal kernel and so therefore there
are many variants of metropolis hastings
algorithm and the real question is how
do you choose your your proposal kernel
in a good way
so here are some simple choices
so the easiest choice maybe is to choose
your proposal distribution independently
of where you currently are so
independently of x
so just choose it always equal to mu
that's called the independent sampler
and that gives you a message which is
quite similar to acceptance rejection
it's not the same but it has similar
properties
you can study it precisely and you see
that it basically works well and in the
same situations where acceptance
rejection works well
okay so this this doesn't help us a lot
but there are situations where you can
use it or you can use it as an
ingredient in more complicated things
okay as second simple possibility is the
random walk metropolis algorithm
so here your proposal kernel is the
transition kernel of a random walk so
that means you propose
to make a transition of a random walk so
that means if you're at x
you you jump to a point
which is distributed around x and for
for example you assume that it's
normally distributed around x
with a given variance h times the
identity matrix
and here h is a fixed constant so that's
something like a step size for your
proposal
okay so in that case you can check that
the proposal density is symmetric
and so therefore your acceptance
probability simplifies
so the expression for the acceptance
probability is now just e to the minus
the positive part of u of y minus u of x
okay and your proposal in that case is
just if you're at x
then you move to x plus square root h
set where that is a standard normal
random variable
okay i'll come back to that in a moment
but before that let me mention something
we come back to later
so you can
do a somehow better adjusted proposal by
taking into account the gradient of your
function u
and so that gives the metropolis
adjusted launcher algorithm so here you
make the following proposal
so
you first move like in gradient descent
so you move from x to x minus h times
nabla u of x
and then you add a random perturbation
so you add square root to h times the
standard normal random variable
we will see later why this is reasonable
so that's some
stochastic perturbation of gradient
descent that you use as your proposal
and then you put your metropolis wasting
step
yeah so that would be another
possibility
okay so now let's go back to random work
metropolis and
yeah i will now for several algorithms i
will just look at them in the case of a
standard normal target distribution
of course nobody is interested in
sampling from a standard normal target
distribution but it's not nevertheless a
good message to see
which problems could occur with the
algorithm
yeah so
let's look at random work metropolis
where your target distribution is this
is just a standard normal distribution
so that means the function u of x is
just quadratic
so this is your proposal
and now we set the acceptance
probability is this one here
the acceptance probability is this one
here
and so we have to look at u of y minus u
of x to study the acceptance probability
okay so what is u of y minus u of x in
that case so y is x plus square root h
times a standard normal
so you just see this gives square root h
x times that
and then you get plus h half
times
the euclidean norm of z squared
and the euclidean norm of z squared
that's the sum of the z i squared
but nowadays that i squared these are
iid
random variables and then you recall for
i for sums of iid random variables you
have a law of large numbers and a
central limit theory so that means you
can study this in high dimensions
so and to do that we just subtract the
expectation value
so that's this one here and then we add
it again here
yeah and now you see
this quantity is now
a sum of centered standard standard
normal random variables and so it's of
stochastic order square root d by the
central limit theorem
okay so that means this term here is
roughly of order h times square root d
whereas this term is of order h times d
and then you see that this last term is
dominant if hd is
large so that means if hd is large then
this quantity will typically be large
but if this quantity is large
then you see your acceptance probability
is very small
okay so from this you see
if hd is large your acceptance
probability will be typically very small
and you can make that precise so you
have this bound here
on the acceptance probability so that
means the probability that the
acceptance probability is greater than
this small number is very small so this
is some posit fixed positive constant
okay so that means most of the time you
will not accept it will be very unlikely
that you accept your proposed move in
this case if hd is large
and that means it will not mix well if
hd is large
okay so this gives me the opportunity to
introduce a quantity like by which we
can link this to the mixing time
and that's the conductance
okay so what is the conductance
the conductance gives us well both lower
and upper bounds for the mixing time but
it's often used to get lower bouncing
so
to introduce the conductance we first
define the equilibrium flow from a set a
to the set b
that's this q a b here so that's just
the integral over a with respect to the
measure mu of pi x b
so this is the probability that
before your move so if you start with
the measure mu then it's the probability
that before the move you're in the set a
and after the move you're in the set b
yeah so that's the equilibrium flow from
a to b
and then
you somehow have a problem with mixing
if you have a set or if you have two
disjoint sets such that the equilibrium
flow
between these sets is small but the sets
have both last large mass
and that's measured by the conductance
so the conductance is just the quotient
of the flow from a to a complement
divided by the minimum of the masses of
a and a complement
so that's the conductance of the set a
so for example if you look at this
probability measure on r1
then you see there's a bottleneck here
so you see if you have a local algorithm
it might have problems moving through
this bottleneck
and that can be quantified by the
conductance
namely you can now look at
this set a here
[Music]
and then you
you set a complement
will be this one here
and the boundary will be here
and in that case if you have some local
algorithm then the flow from a to a
complement will be small but the mass of
both sets will be large so the
conductance will be small
yeah so the conductance gives you a way
to see bottlenecks
and now you have the following theorem
which is also not so difficult to prove
so if the mass of a is smaller than one
half say
then the total variation mixing time of
the set a
is bounded from below by one over four
times the conductance of a
so this one quarter here this is quite
arbitrary you could you could replace
that by another epsilon and then you
would just get another constant here
yeah so that's not important
what is important is that the inverse of
the conductance gives you a lower bound
for the mixing time
and so the nice thing about this hearing
is that this is valid completely
generally so you don't need any
assumption on your markov chain for this
okay so for example for your random work
metropolis algorithm you see now that
the mixing time of n if you start in any
ball around the origin
is greater than one over eight e to the
h e over four
and now you immediately see that if hd
is large
your mixing time will be very very large
so you immediately see that you have to
choose your step size
of order d inverse at least
[Music]
and so here you see a problem of the
random walk metropolis algorithm even if
you could achieve this
upper bound here which is not clear
but even if you could do
you you still would have to choose h of
order d inverse
okay so the conductance
also provides upper bounds on mixing
times well not not quite it actually
provides upper bounds on l2 relaxation
times
and
this can be used to get bounce on mixing
times but you have to assume a warm
start we'll come back to that later so
you cannot start from an arbitrary
initial value
okay but
there's also a converse to that result
okay because of these problems
of
random work metropolis
it seems reasonable to look for improved
proposals
and so the idea is similar to
what we saw yesterday now the next step
would be to go to a first order method
so that means take into account the
gradient of u
and that's what we want to do now
but in order to do that i like first to
move into continuous time
because it helps us clarify the concepts
yeah so similar also to what we saw in
optimization we will first look at
continuous time things and then
afterwards we will look at how to
discretize them
and how to get algorithms in discrete
time
okay any
are there any questions up to here so
now we would start with the next part
uh there's something in the chat i
i'm not able to really follow it check
let's see uh
okay no but that's not a question okay
okay so if you have questions just just
interrupt just ask
okay so now we move to continuous time
and
so we come to what is called over damped
launch learn dynamics which is a
continuous time markov process with the
right invariant measure so we still have
our invariant map we still have our
measure mu with density proportional to
e to the minus u of x
but now we want to find a continuous
time markov process which has this
measure as invariant measure
and
this you can do by looking by looking at
a stochastic differential equation so
what you look at is the following so you
look at an equation dx t is equal to b x
t dt
so without this noise term this is just
like an ode this is just the ode
generated by the vector field b
and then you add this noise term which
is square root two
times the increment of a brownian motion
yeah so that's a quite simple stochastic
differential equation
and if you choose b in the right way
then you get mu of s as your invariant
measure
so how do you have to choose b well
you can choose b for example exactly
equal to minus the gradient of u
and then we again back to what we saw
yesterday so then here we would have
just gradient descent
just just gradient flow and then here we
have a stochastic perturbation of the
gradient flow
yeah so that's somehow the easiest
choice that you can do
but there are also other choices so you
can actually add here
another vector field beta with certain
properties and you will still have the
right invariant measure
and
this is what the following theorem says
well first of all it says that under
certain conditions you have have a
solution of this sde and it defines the
markov process
so you need some condition on the drift
this one here so this just guarantees
that your solution does not explode
so if if you assume this condition
then for every initial law so for every
initial law on you
you have a unique non-explosive
strong solution
of this stochastic differential equation
and you can also show that this solution
defines a strong markov process
and
so this now has a transition function
the transition function now depends on t
we're in continuous time
and i now use the notation ptf of x so
that's just the integral with respect to
your transition kernel at time t
of the function f of y
and pdf of x is just the expectation of
f of x t
if you start
at position x
so that's your transition function and
this now forms a semi group so pspt is
equal to pt plus s
and then
you can also identify the generator of
this
and at least a nice function so on
compactly supported smooth functions
uh the generator lf is given by la plus
f plus b times nabla f
now so this b times nabla f that would
be the generator of the ode
and this laplacian here that's the
generator of of the brownian motion part
and now you have both together here
okay and this limit
you can take in this case for example in
the supremum
okay so you have a solution and then you
ask when do when is mu an invariant
measure for this
and and you find that this is the case
if and only if the divergence of e to
the minus u times beta vanishes
this is some somehow some divergence of
beta with respect to the measure mu
so if this divergence of beta with
respect to the measurement vanishes
then
the sde with this drift here will have
the right invariant measure
okay on the other hand you may ask when
do we have detailed balance which is a
stronger condition and turns out this is
only the case if your drift is exactly
minus the gradient of u so this is only
the case if beta vanishes
okay so how do you prove this
uh
yeah maybe just briefly so the generator
you identify by stochastic analysis
using ito's formula now to check for the
invariance that's maybe interesting for
us since we need the right invariant
measure
so so you want to check if mu pt is
equal to mu for all t
now
you integrate a function f with respect
to these two measures
then you see by fubini's theory
that this is equivalent to saying that
the integral of ptfd mu is the same as
the integral of f d
d mu for all measurable functions f
okay and now
you can see that if this holds then by
differentiating in t
you get that the integral of lft mu
vanishes
where l is the generator the generator
some somehow like the derivative of ptf
at time zero
so from this you can conclude that
integral lft mu vanishes but you can
also go back
going back is not so trivial you you
need some analysis for this you have to
show that
these functions that you have these test
functions form a core for your operator
but with the appropriate analysis in
this case you can also go back
okay so you see that invariance is
equivalent to this condition
and now if you write down your generator
and integrate by parts
then you see that this is equivalent to
this divergence condition
so you see in variance holds exactly in
this case
and well you can also check that if b is
just minus the gradient of u so if the
beta vanishes
then
by integration by parts you see that
this integral lfgd mu
is symmetric in fng so it just
distinguishedly form integral napla f
nabla gdmu so it's symmetric and this
symmetry implies that also your
transition function is a symmetric
linear operator and that turns out to be
equivalent to the detailed balance
condition
okay so you see that you have detailed
balance if and only if b is a negative
gradient of u and but you have
invariance also for other drifts
okay so now that you have that you ask
what can we say about convergence to
equilibrium for this markov process in
continuous time
okay and in order to do that there are
these different approaches that i
mentioned before
and we start with the coupling approach
so for the coupling approach you need a
distance on probability measures
and the simplest distance
simplest appropriate distance to use
here is an lp wasserstein distance so
what what is the lp washer stein
distance between u and mu
well that's just
you do the following you sample x from
new so you take two random variables x
and y which are defined on the same
probability space
and such that x has law nu and y has law
mu
two such random variables are called a
coupling
or more precisely a realization of a
coupling of the measures mu and u
okay and now you just look at the p
distance of these two random variables
so you just look at the p distance of x
and y
now of course this lp distance depends
on the coupling that you choose and can
be very large
but now you look for the optimal
coupling so that means you take the
infimum of this lp distance over all
couplings of mu and mu
and that defines the lp wasserstein
distance between u and mu
which is a very natural distance on
probability measures
okay so that's one possibility and you
see here
you you apply some convex function to
the difference x minus y in this case so
there's some convexity here
because of this you can also look at the
counterpart where instead of something
convex here you put something concave
that gives this distance is wf
so here instead of of applying a convex
function you apply a concave function f
to x minus y and then you do the same
so of course not an arbitrary concave
function but one that maps 0 infinity to
0 infinity that maps 0 to zero which is
non-decreasing and convex
so i have nine functions that look like
this so usually they will be continuous
but they might have a jump at zero and
they are convex
and
non-decreasing yeah so you take such a
function applied to x minus y
and then you take the same
and that defines also a wasserstein
distance actually an one wasserstein
distance but with respect to a different
metric which is defined by this concave
function f
question
i'm a bit confused you're using convex
and concave uh can you tell us what is
convex what is concave yeah
sorry
this is of course a concave function
yeah so here we have a convex function
here we have a concave function
thanks
okay
so we look at these two uh
distances
so why is the second distance
interesting uh well first of all one can
often prove bounds in these distances
where one cannot prove bounce in the lp
washtein distances
and
secondly this distance also includes the
total variation distance for example
so if you take f of t just the indicator
function that t is positive
then and and then you look at this wf
then you have here the infimum
of the probability that x is not equal
to y
over all couplings x and y and that's
exactly the coupling characterization of
the total variation distance between u
and u
now so the total variation distance is
somehow an extreme case of these wf
distances
[Music]
okay so now we have distances and so
these distances turn out to be useful in
connection with couplings so why is that
this is because suppose you have a
coupling x t y t of your markov pro of
two markov processes
the markov process which starts at some
initial or new and has the transition
function pt
and the markov process with the same
transition function but starting at
initial or mu
what is the coupling of these two markov
processes so this is just
a markov process on the product space
such that the first component is a
markov process with initial or new and
transition function pt and the second
component
is such a markov process
okay so suppose you have such a coupling
well then xt
has law nu pt and yt has law mu pt
and so therefore by the coupling
definition of the wasserstein distance
you can bound the lp wasserstein
distance between upt and upt
by the lp distance between xt and yt
yeah and
so now in particular if mu is your
invariant measure
mu is your invariant measured and this
is just equal to mu
and then you have fear bound on the lp
wasserstein distance between your law at
time t
and your target distribution mu
so you can use couplings to get bounds
on these wasserstein distances and
exactly the same for these distances wf
okay so now how do i get couplings of
two diffusion processes
[Music]
well
so what you should have is you should
have two markov processes defined on the
same probability space which satisfy the
same sde
but start at different initial laws
okay and which choice do i have in that
case well there's only one choice i have
i can choose these brownian motions here
in particular i can choose how the two
are related to each other
so they might be the same they might be
independent and there are other
possibilities
yeah so that's the only choice i have
and and each choice for these brownian
notions
defines a coupling of these processes
okay so now how can i connect these two
brownian motions well the easiest way is
just to choose them equal
so you choose b twiddle equal to b
and that's called a synchronous coupling
and that's the most widely used coupling
okay let's do that let's consider this
coupling so we just have two solutions
of our process with different initial
laws
but they satisfy the same as the e with
the same brownian motion
well then we can just take difference of
the two so we can just look at x t minus
y t
and then the noise cancels because they
have the same brownian notion
and you just get an ode for the
difference
so the time derivative of x minus y is
just v of x minus b of y
yeah same type of thing as we saw
yesterday
and then you know well how to study this
equation well you know that
if we now have this condition here which
i call a k
if x minus y times b of x minus b of y
is
bounded from above by minus k times x
minus y squared
which in the case where b is the
negative gradient of u is just k strong
convexity
so if we have this condition
for some positive constant k
then we get exponential decay
even point wise since it's an ode
and as a consequence of that you
immediately get that also all these lp
wasserstein distances decay
exponentially
for every p
okay so the proof is is
easy so the first part i think everybody
here knows how to do that so i leave it
to you
and
so for the second part you just have to
note
that this distance here is defined as an
infimum over all couplings of mu and mu
so we want to bound this side here by an
infimum over all couplings
so that means we take an arbitrary
coupling of new and mu
so take an arbitrary coupling x zero y
zero
and then you evolve your markov process
your coupled markov process and then
delay it
the process at time t x t y t
has marginal loss nu p t and u p t so
that means this defines the coupling of
new p t and u p t
and that means you can bound the l p
wasserstein distance of mu p t nu pt by
the lp norm of xt minus yt
and then you just apply this bond you
just insert this bound here and then you
get your exponential decay
and now you just minimize overall
couplings of new and new and then on the
right hand side you get this
weisserstein distance
okay so that's very easy
and there are
nice features so it's easy moreover the
result is somehow sharp
so if
this supremum here
is greater equal to zero then you can
also show that you do not not have
strict
wasserstein contractivity for any p
between 1 and infinity
so in that sense the result is sharp
what's also nice the dimension does not
enter at all so it's completely
dimension free and what's nice is you
have a contraction in some distance and
if you have that it's quite robust
yeah so that's very nice but of course
there are also
disadvantages
first disadvantage it only applies in
the strongly context case
yeah that's because it's sharp
secondly uh the noise has been kicked
out
yeah so if when we look at the coupling
difference then the noise disappears so
it's not used at all in our argument
but now people would say
that the noise can be beneficial for the
mixing properties
so somehow
you should make use of the noise and
here you just throw it away
okay so that's the disadvantage and then
another disadvantage is that you cannot
get total variation bounds
with this method
this is because the two copies just come
closer and closer together exponentially
but they never reach the same point if
you do synchronous coupling so they
never meet each other and because of
that it doesn't give you total variation
bounce
okay so you see it's nice but it has
some disadvantage and so therefore you
might ask if we can do something else
and
yeah maybe i just introduce what you can
do before the break and then we go into
the break
so there's another coupling which has
been introduced by lindvale and rogers
and that's called reflection coupling
and in that case you do not use the same
noise for both copies but you do the
following so suppose
your first copy is at position x t and
your second copy is here at position y t
so these two positions
but now you have a drift
which brings them apart so you no longer
have strong convexity so they move apart
by the deterministic dynamics
can you nevertheless have some good
mixing properties and of course you can
but you have to use the noise
okay and how how can you do that
what you do is
you you define
the the noise increments by reflection
so you put a hyperplane between the two
current positions x t and y t that's
this hyper plane here
and then if you have here this noise
increment dbt
this is all of course only
formally now because this is an
infinitesimal noise increment but
formally if you have this infinitesimal
noise increment dbt here
then you reflect it on that hyperplane
and take the reflected increment for the
other process
so why do you want to do that
well later you want to look at you you
you get included in your equations the
difference of these two increments
now if the difference shows in the
direction connecting the two then that
might help you
then sometimes you will move closer
together and sometimes you will move
further apart so on average you will not
gain but sometimes you will come closer
together and that might help you
on the other hand moving in in the
orthogonal directions will not help you
so if this moves somehow in the
orthogonal direction and this moves
differently in your signal direction
this will only increase your distance
yeah so that will never help you
so therefore in the orthogonal
directions you don't want noise but in
the direction connecting the two you
want noise
and this you can do you can define your
second brownian motion by this equation
here which is just
translating this picture into mass so
this is an e2 differential equation
so your increment of betwiddle is your
increment of b
and then you reflect it at the typer
plane and this is just the reflection at
the hyperlink
so et is the unit vector connecting the
two
and you do that reflection as long as
they are not at the same position
otherwise you choose the same noise
yeah that's called reflection coupling
and you can show that this really
defines again brownian motion
b twiddle and
so you can really define this coupling
process and and that will give you
some improved conditions
okay so then i would stop here for the
first part and then
yeah maybe you have questions and
otherwise
be back in after the break
questions
the audio is not so good i understood
something with hyperplane and sorry
um yeah i was wondering how do you
choose the hyperplane
the hyperplane is just the hyperplane in
the middle between xt and yt so all
points that have the same distance of x
t and y t
the time t cost
change
sorry
the hyper plane changes with t was that
your question yes it changes with t
that's very important
so it's randomly moving
the questions
all right actually yeah go ahead
so as you mentioned this coupling i mean
maybe we'll get back to this but this
coupling allows sometimes them to get
closer and sometimes make them go away
is there a way to find a coupling that
always gets them closer
no
you somehow do not have a free lunch but
nevertheless we will see that this
coupling is already quite good
all right somehow if you change this
brownian motion you only change the
martingale part in your e2 equation
and for the martingale part of course if
you take average you do not gain
all right no more questions and join me
in thanking address again
so we have a break
uh i guess we start again at
11 is that right yeah all right
[Music]